things getting nasty in the Battle of
Governors slick-haired leader Gavin
Newsom is threatening to slap Ron
DeSantis with kidnapping charges for
sending two plane loads of migrants to
California's capital Newsome furiously
tweeting this threat Out quote Ron
DeSantis you small pathetic man this
isn't Martha's Vineyard kidnapping
charges the Tweet then linking to a
screenshot of a section of California
Penal Code
Florida officials telling Fox that they
flew the migrants to California but got
their verbal and written consent to do
so
not so gracious Gavin who once boasted
about being a sanctuary state is also
sicking his henchmen on DeSantis Cali's
attorney general taking this pot shot at
Florida
we believe that the State of Florida
Governor DeSantis is behind it Governor
DeSantis has demonstrated his pettiness
his lack of substance his xenophobia and
his uh discrimination and racism and his
willingness to treat human beings people
as political pawns it's wrong and we are
getting to the bottom of it and while
those two Governors duke it out over the
migrant crisis the White House is
getting mocked for complaining that the
migrant buses are putting a strain on
cities
bussing or flying migrants around the
country without any coordination with
the federal government we've talked
about this state or local officials as
well is dangerous and unacceptable and
will continue to be very very clear
about that it is dangerous and
unacceptable because you're putting
people's lives at risk and it's
dangerous and it's unacceptable because
you're actually putting a lot of
pressure on these states and local uh
and local local areas New York City is
also getting slammed by the migrant
crisis so bad mayor Eric Adams wants to
pay New Yorkers to house the city's
migrants
it is my vision uh to take the next step
to this to go to the faith base uh
locales and then move to a private
residence they are residents who are
suffering right now because of economic
challenges they have spare rooms we can
take that 4.2 billion dollars 4.3 it may
be now that we potentially have to spend
and we can put it back into pockets of
everyday New Yorkers everyday houses of
worship instead of putting in the
pockets of Corporations all right so
judge there's a lot to talk about here
but can Gavin Newsom bring up Ron
DeSantis on kidnapping charges no that's
ridiculous and you know what I don't
even want to waste time on that because
that's absurd first of all you can't get
a D.A in the state of California to do
anything now he wants them to bring
charges against uh Ron DeSantis look
what is happening in this country is
absurd there is this overarching issue
of chaos where the left is like
basically taking down everything all of
the the institutions all of the all of
the different agencies are getting
involved everybody's fighting with each
other you've got Governors going after
Governors you've got a mayor going after
County Executives trying to move these
illegals into the northern part of New
York State you've got everybody fighting
with each other nobody's fighting with
the president it's like all of us are
waiting for someone to come in and say
the adult in the room to say children
stop fighting with each other this is
what we're going to do but there is no
one in charge Joe Biden is literally
aiding and abetting the entrance of
foreign Nationals into this country
about whom we know nothing all right and
the idea that that that that that Adams
the mayor in New York City is now
starting with this kind of leftist
socialist Marxist we're going to put
them in your house what are you talking
about Mr Mayor I mean you've got half of
the half of the hotels in New York City
filled with these illegal illegals you
tried to put them in the gyms at schools
now you're going to tell us we need to
house them and by the way this whole
idea of you know we can put money back
in the pockets of everyday New Yorkers
who are you kidding first of all if you
have someone who's an orphan in foster
care it's forty dollars a day you get
but you house an illegal the churches
are getting 125 dollars a day so it's a
little extra cash going in there right
what are they going to do next are they
the left gonna knock on my door and say
Janine you got too many bedrooms here I
want to put illegals in your house this
is not the America that we voted for
that we were born into and by the way I
think if you're a sanctuary state if you
promoted Sanctuary cities policies or
any of that you should take two for free
all of you
Dana printer you were exhaling uh quite
loudly also during the that introduction
anything you want to touch on well a
couple of things first of all I don't
think that Rhonda Santos thinks of
Governor Newsom as a rival okay I think
that Governor Newsom doesn't realize
that nobody's paying attention to him
and that he is just helping Ron DeSantis
by reminding everybody that he was the
one that was willing to do something to
try to get the government's attention to
do something about the migrant crisis so
I think that's ridiculous plus he's not
even bold enough to say DeSantis you are
guilty of kidnapping and you're going to
be prosecuted he instead he used a
little question mark right like
kidnapping charges like oh like that is
just childish and I think DeSantis
probably wins in that one for a long
time conservatives have said if you
think open borders are okay then why
don't you Nancy Pelosi have one of them
living in your house right and they
would roll their eyes at any
conservative that would say that and now
it's actually their policy plan this is
something you can just imagine this is
the an idea that probably should have
gone by the wayside but they're trying
they're grasping at straws but they're
mad at everybody except for Biden and
what sort of disaster could result from
bringing somebody who is not vetted into
somebody's home and we're going to give
them 125 a day I think Janine's
absolutely right think of the foster
children in this country today people
think people take in foster kids because
of the money they absolutely do not
that's because of heart well Greg's
already taken three illegals then that's
great that's just your money for the
weekend yeah we just hang out back it's
sun it's incredible she cringe is right
though cringe you do put people at risk
when you send them to Liberal cities
finally a Democrat says that this is the
best dating app ever you're marrying
policies to outcomes in places where you
can feel it which is what we've been
talking about and they're flipping
Sacramento they're flipping out over 16
migrants right I've seen 16 people in
Larry kudlow's hot tub it's not a lot
and and uh the fact is didn't they fly
private they flew private which kind of
sucks because I know Jesse you still do
coach at Spirit so uh next to the
bathroom yeah but I think when you're
dealing with stupid people and Gavin
might just be the dumbest person in in
politics you do have to State the
obvious that when people happily go with
you it's not kidnapping adults go
happily with you it's not kidnapping if
that's true we're gonna have to file
charges against every major airline so
it's it's like it's kind of sad it's
like what the judge said she didn't want
to comment on it because they're so
stupid yeah but this is a teachable
moment one for Gavin it's not enough to
have good hair or be handsome I learned
this early in life you have to develop
strategies you have to develop
strategies and skills to be persuasive
you just can't call somebody a pathetic
little man I know this and don't virtue
signal if you have no virtue so that's
the best part about this they gained a
lot of compassion over the decades with
the sanctuary City BS and now all it
took is one slight Push by the
Republicans something that we were
talking about and this virtual Sanctuary
just crumbled right before you it makes
you wonder should have done this should
have done this first and it puts it puts
Republicans on The High Ground why are
you complaining you xenophobes why are
you it's like it's like they're trying
to call the right xenophobes when
they're flipping out when when
immigrants who come to them and then the
last about this Adam's thing I give him
credit for trying to walk the walk
however these are not good ideas but
he's saying we're a sanctuary City I'm
going to try to live by the rule of a
sanctuary City but if you agree to uh
voluntarily house these people who vets
them like if you're like you know I like
yeah I have you know I do have three
people staying in my house but I vetted
them I got them off Craigslist but in
this case in this case who's vetting
them no one no one it's crazy how long
can they stay what if they could stay
forever because you don't have any rules
there is a simpler solution follow the
law
all right follow that
so
um I think this this matter helps both
of them politically in their own states
and their own parties both I think to
Dana's point desant is probably an
exchange because he's an announced
candidate gets gets a bit more credit
because you're going to remind voters
that he was probably the first he and
Governor Abbott to engage in this this
little bit of a stunt to sadly it's not
advancing any solution I think it's
again it's a political stunt but it's
not advancing any solution the
politicians seem to be only out for
themselves and trying to advance their
own personal interests and I would agree
who knows what governor Newsom is going
to do in this race or if he's not going
to do anything the race if he's going to
run it appears that the politics of
these issues takes precedence supersedes
wanting to get to the substance and
solving it we've talked about for years
on this show I've been fortunate to be
on the show now for a few years and the
fact that we have not built a wall the
fact that we've not reformed our Asylum
process the fact that we've not if we
think this is a national security issue
that we've not put more law enforcement
and Ice officers on on the border the
fact that we have not figured out ways
to address some of the worker shortage
challenges we have if we were to get
serious about it is is really the the
thing that bothers me the most Governor
Newsom and Governor DeSantis have the
potential if they were to come together
and say we're going to go to Washington
and we're going to ask for we're going
to we're going to demand a meeting with
President Biden and members of Congress
to say this is what you need to be doing
they could gather all of the governors
all the governors not one Governor would
reject the two of them saying let's go
and figure out ways in which to solve
this so the stunts that you know I'm I'm
not I'm not one that don't belittle
anyone it hasn't been done well if I
were a governor that's what I would be
doing if I were president if I'd be
doing but I'll tell you why it's not
being done everybody advances their own
narrow political interest Governor
DeSantis is getting something out of
this and so is Governor Newsom you know
who the losers are you me and every
other taxpayer particularly here in New
York for the illegals because it's all
on the states Medicaid education overrun
schools hospitals Medicaid is a lot of
upsets on the federal government
immigration
you forgot to say it's good to be back
around the table yeah I thought it was
imply all right hi everyone I'm Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now